починаємся українці борються за захист
суверенітету своєї країни і в очах
багатьох на заході вони також борються і
гинуть захищаючи європейські цінності
тим хто зможе гарантувати для України
безпеки в майбутньому чи буде це ЄС чи
можливо Сполучені Штати чи зможе Україна
стати повноправним членом НАТО чи вступ
до Північного Атлантичного Альянсу так і
залишиться нездійсненною мрією
справа не в тому заслуговує Україна на
це чи ні Справа в тому чи заслуговують
всі інші на те щоб Україна прагнула до
цього
Ukraine безумовно Україна повинна бути в
НАТО але націю яка воює не приймуть до
Альянсу
нині ми повинні зосередитися на тому щоб
допомогти Україні виграти цю війну і
відкинути російські війська зі своєї
території
ми знаходимося поруч із штаб-квартирою
НАТО в Брюсселі і прямо за моєю спиною
ви бачите барвисті національні прапори
всіх країн НАТО українці впевнені
питання Коли тут займають і їхній прапор
це лише питання часу але це може
призвести до прямого конфлікту Альянсу з
Росією чого за словами офіційних осіб
вони хочуть уникнути будь-якою ціною тож
куди приведуть амбіції України щодо
вступу в НАТО і яким може бути результат
давайте разом розглянемо три можливі
сцена
сценарій першої дорожня карта вступу в
НАТО
Ольга стефанішина докладає всіх зусилля
аби це стало можливим її посада
віце-прем'єрка України з питань
євроатлантичної інтеграції від початку
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії вона
регулярно їздить до брюсселя і
намагається наполегливо переконувати
тутешніх чиновників відкрити для України
шлях до членства в НАТО
ми довели як країна що ми надійним
партнером навіть під час повномасштабної
війни
без участі України буквально неможливо
сформувати будь-яку стратегію безпеки ми
відстоюємо наші інтереси у момент коли
рішення має бути прийняте і цей момент
тут і зараз справа не в тому заслуговує
Україна на це чи ні Справа в тому чи
заслуговують всі інші на те щоб Україна
прагнула до цього
українські військові вже нині воюють
зброєю західного виробництва пройшли
військову підготовку в країнах членах
НАТО і показали що вони є першою лінією
оборони Європи зрештою Україна чекає на
можливість вступу до НАТО вже
багато-багато років ще до того як Росія
вирішила використати це як привід для
свого вторгнення
у 2008 році лідери країн-членів НАТО
зібралися на саміті у бухаресті і
зробили історичну заяву Ось що вони
сказали
НАТО вітає євроатлантичні прагнення
України та Грузії щодо членства в НАТО
Сьогодні ми домовилися що ці країни
стануть членами НАТО
але коли саме і за яких обставин ці
важливі питання залишилися без відповіді
і з тих пір якось далі Україна не
просунулася чому
на той час генеральним секретарем НАТО
був я б де хопсхепфер
лідери НАТО на цьому відомому саміті
2008 року привітали прагнення України
але не запросили Україну розпочати
переговори про вступ чи була Це помилка
таким був баланс таким був компроміс а
компроміс ніколи не є ідеальним
варіантом а там було далеко до ідеалу
Хоча я відразу визнаю що мені як
генеральному секретарю довелося захищати
таке рішення тому що йшлося про те про
що домовилися президент Буш канцлерка
Меркель і президент саркозій Але ви були
незадоволені результатом тоді у 2008-му
Я думав що це найкращий компроміс який
ми могли придумати але проблема з цим
компромісом полягала в тому що я
процитую мого друга Курта волкера
колишнього послав НАТО та
спецпредставника США з питань України ми
залишили Україну у сірій зоні А далі
Курт волкер справедливо додав що сірі
зони залишають можливість для зеленого
світла тому оскільки Україна лишилася у
сірій зоні Путін сприйняв це як зелене
світло він вторгся в Грузію у 2008 році
Далі він вторгся в Крим і анексував його
в 2014 році Він здійснив повномасштабне
вторгнення у лютому 2022 року сірі зони
- це зелене світло і Ніколи знову Ми не
повинні дозволити цьому повторитися у
2008 році саме Німеччина Та Франція
виступили проти вступу України до
Альянсу через побоювання спровокувати
Росію сьогодні союзники знову
сперечаються про те як коли і чи
запрошувати Україну вступати до Альянсу
і Німеччина знову опинилася серед тих
країн-членів НАТО які ставляться до
цього з обережністю
Я готовий відповісти на це питання вже
20-й раз є чіткі заяви з боку НАТО що
Україна має майбутнє в НАТО Але разом з
тим усім зацікавленим зрозуміло що про
прийняття країни яка перебуває у стані
війни просто не може бути мови це має
бути зрозуміло усім тому що тоді НАТО
стане стороною у війні а сьогодні ніхто
не хоче
тож обережно ставляться до потенційного
членства України Українці - це теж
розуміють поки на території країни
точиться війна країна не може стати
членом НАТО і ось чому країни НАТО
беруть на себе зобов'язання щодо
колективної оборони щоб захистити одна
одну в разі нападу це обіцянка відома як
п'ята стаття договору НАТО лежить в
основі Альянсу це зобов'язання і є той
щит якого так прагне Україна водночас
він і є найбільшою перешкодою для вступу
країну яка перебуває у стані війни не з
її власної вини а в агресивній війні з
боку Росії її не приймуть до Альянсу
тому що це означало б що згідно з п'ятою
статтею в напад на одного з членів
Альянсу є нападом на всіх його членів
тобто тоді мала б застосуватися п'ята
стаття і НАТО опинився безпосередньо у
стані війни з Росією це те чого немає
статися
натомість НАТО може запропонувати
Україні дорожню карту до членства тобто
що потрібно зробити Києву щоб стати
членом Альянсу одразу після закінчення
війни це те на чому наполягають багато
політичних прихильників України серед
яких Польща та країни Балтії
Естонія завжди дотримувалася позиції що
найкращою або навіть єдиною гарантією
безпеки для України є членство в НАТО Це
очевидно бо Росія багато десятиліть
заявляла що вони хочуть створити буферні
сірі зони між Росією та НАТО і нашим
зустрічним меседжем завжди було те що
між Росією та нато не може бути жодної
сірої зони і що кожна країна має свободу
вирішувати а НАТО має політику відкритих
дверей
з нашої точки зору з точки зору Польщі
Україна повинна бути членом НАТО тому що
це доказ нашої спільної безпеки
і звичайно ми повинні бути єдиними Ось
чому ми відкриті для обговорення цього
питання На мою думку ми повинні
представити конкретний шлях досягнення
цієї мети і я сподіваюся що під час
зустрічі НАТО у Вільнюсі цей шлях буде
представлено
це може бути певний термін хронологія
багато хто вважає що дорожня карта до
членства найкращий варіант для України з
огляду на війну цей сценарій також
розглядають тут у Брюсселі однак це
водночас і надважкий тягач для українців
адже виходить якщо Україна не виграє
війну то членство в НАТО так і
залишиться недосяжним тому є думки що
Україна має відмовитися від своєї мрії
про НАТО і розглянути інші можливі
безпекові сценарії
сценарій другий нейтралітет
НАТО було створено після Другої світової
війни це Альянс держава Північної
Америки та західної Європи створений для
стримування загроз з боку Радянського
Союзу
після Холодної війни країни які колись
перебували за залізною завісою також
постукали у двері НАТО саме тоді сталося
історичне розширення Альянсу на Схід
але є й інший варіант деякі Європейські
країни вирішили не приєднуватися до НАТО
і натомість обрали військовий
нейтралітет такі країни як Австрія
Ірландія та Швейцарія проводять політику
не приєднання що іноді навіть прописано
в Конституції з метою уникнути участі у
міжнародних конфліктах Росія традиційно
розглядає розширення НАТО як загрози у
власній безпеці що Альянс постійно
заперечує Кремль заявляє що якщо НАТО
назавжди зачинити свої двері перед
Україною вторгнення закінчиться
сьогодні треба виходити із того що
розширення НАТО розвиток військової
інфраструктури біля російських кордонів
є однією з потенційних загроз безпеці
нашої країни
колишній генсек НАТО я б де хопсхепфер
вважає що ця заява бере початок ще з
подій у давно забутому минулому
гадаю Володимиром Путіним керує
Одержимість і ця Одержимість сягає 1989
року коли впав Берлінський мур усе що
він сповідував розвалилося і він хоче
відновити і воскресити цей світ який в
ідеалі є світом царської імперії
радянської імперії Ось що ним керує
однак для України це означало
відмовця брута
льними все що служить російським
амбіціям виправдовує агресію Росія каже
що якщо Україна буде нейтральною то вони
не будуть нападати але це просто вигадка
цитує чи російського письма яка ці слова
Не варті навіть паперу на якому вони
написані тож якщо є така дискусія ця
дискусія виправдовує війну а ще
виправдовує злочини напади на цивільних
осіб убитих і поранених і всю масово
різанину яку ми пережили протягом війни
шоковані жорстокістю війни Росії проти
України дедалі більше партнерів України
на заході розуміють що вибір
нейтралітету не захистить Україну від
нової російської агресії натомість За
зачиненими дверима США спільно з деякими
європейськими країнами невпино працюють
над гарантіями безпеки які вони могли б
запропонувати Україні
Ukraine такі гарантії не означатимуть що
ці країни захищатимуть Україну військову
в разі нового нападу але вони
забезпечать Україну зброєю передовими
технологіями навчанням і грошима і є ще
щось що має підсолодити такі гарантії
Україна має стати членом Європейського
Союзу
вражаюче бачити що незважаючи на
повномасштабну війну Україна наполегливо
вони в тому та інтенсивно працює на
цьому мав кроками для вступу в ЄС вже
досягнуто значного прогресу але роботу
потрібно продовжувати
поки захід навряд чи проситиме Київ
ввести переговори з Москвою особливо без
чітких поступок з боку Росії у відповідь
Але не слід виключати таку можливість
особливо якщо війна затягнеться на руки
а російські війська продовжуватимуть
окупацію української території і це
підводить нас до останнього сценарію
сценарій третій режим очікування
члени НАТО неодноразово давали високою
оцінку ЗСУ за те що вони успішно
відбивають напади Росії Утім зрозуміло
що це було б значно складніше без
підтримки заходу союзники України Такі
як США Німеччина Та Великобританія
надсилають Київу дедалі сучаснішу
технологічну військову підтримку як
танки леопард-2 система протиповітряної
оборони патріот або артилерійський
ракетні комплекси хаймерс але що буде
якщо запаси вичерпаються
лідери НАТО запевняють що цього не
станеться
війна в Україні лише демонструє
необхідність підтримувати Україну нині і
робити це надалі
у США наступного року а також враховуючи
позицію окремих найвищих політичних осіб
в країнах членах НАТО таких як Угорщина
довгострокова підтримка об'єднаного
заходу далеко не гарантована до того ж
ніхто не знає що буде якщо станеться
конфлікт навколо тайваню це відтягнуло б
американський ресурси і уваги від
України в бік Азії
у результаті це призведе до нового
замороженого конфлікту в Україні такий
як Північна та Південна Корея
Придністров'я Нагірний Карабах та
турецька окупація північного Кіпру
Таким чином Україна може залишитися в
сірій зоні стукаючи у двері заходу
шукаючи підтримки хто міг би вислухати
чи сприймати її потреби серйозно Наразі
це виглядає малоймовірним розвитком але
може знадобитися Лише кілька виборів або
гостра інфляційна криза Щоб побачити як
зміниться ставлення в деяких країнах
Заходу
тим не менше можна бути впевненим що
Україна робитиме все для того щоб бути
почутою
є буквально приїжджаю сюди з країни де
триває війна двоє моїх дітей залишаються
в Києві а я тут у Брюсселі Ми не хочемо
бути заручниками якогось політичного
керівництва чи політиків які ухвалюють
рішення ми відстоюємо інтереси лобіюємо
їх у той момент коли рішення має бути
ухвалене і цей момент тут і зараз
моментом і Знав Але зараз не на часі це
слова які швидше за все почує Київ на
саміті у Вільнюсі коли йтиметься про
вступ до НАТО
те що ми можемо спостерігати в
майбутньому це певна комбінація цих
трьох сценаріїв Україна отримає
перспективу членства в НАТО Та певні
форми гарантії безпеки на перехідний
період тим часом Київ далі буде змушений
воювати на двох дуже різних фронтах
військовому щоб захистити свою територію
від Росії і на фронті дипломатичному щоб
переконати захід продовжувати надавати
підтримку в довгостроковій перспективі
підняття українського прапору тут у
штаб-квартирі НАТО поки для України є
мрією мрією яка Можливо колись
здійснюється але здається не зараз і
принаймні не в найближчі кілька років